let me start with congratulations on
werewolf by night I think fans are going
to love this thing I hope so I'm I'm
excited to share it I know it's it's
still a couple weeks away or whatever
but I'm like soon let everyone see it
it's exciting well one of the things
that's great about it is it's so
different than anything else in the MCU
it's something very original
um in terms of well I won't get into the
specifics but do you think this is the
beginning of more specials like this
coming to Disney plus like every year
could there be something you know we
haven't
um set out for uh like you know a
schedule or a master plan or something
like that but I think what's really
exciting about the special is it's
Unique right Disney plus lets us do
something that doesn't have to be a
three-hour movie it doesn't have to be a
you know a 10 episode series it lets us
dip our toe in introduce something bring
out a new character and sort of give you
what I've been calling an appetizer of
hopefully what's more to come with you
know seeing these characters or at least
the ones that lived uh continue on in
the MCU you were and uh I could be I
want to make sure I got this right an
executive coordinator for Kevin feige
what exactly does that mean uh so I was
uh running Kevin's office so I mean I
was getting him to where he needed to be
obviously a traditional Assistant duties
but also helping him uh get to the right
reviews check in travel to set with him
uh attend you know press trunk it's what
what have you you know all things about
Kevin
um and the thing about that was I I
spoke to Kevin when I first was hired
that job I said I want to learn how to
make movies and he's like well get ready
like this is this is it like it's a
crash course Kevin is so Hands-On with
everything that it allowed me to see you
know every step from visual effects to
costumes to you know casting to making
deals and agreements to locations
um he's really touches it all and was
incredible Mentor but also an amazing
Storyteller I mean I I know you've
talked to him I'm sure plenty of times
um he's incredible at what he does and
figuring out amazing Stories you know
he's on another level I mean you can't
you can't do what he's done
um it's just it's never been done in
Hollywood I I have nothing I mean it's
it's insane you know but I'm curious
what do you think would surprise Marvel
fans to learn about what goes on behind
the scenes in like the making of
werewolf by night and what's just going
on in terms of the development of things
at the end at marble sure I mean one of
the things specific to wear off by night
and maybe it's not a surprise but when I
think about it it was surprising me it
was we hired Michael jokino as a direct
he is incredibly talented composer and
has brought all his knowledge to
shooting in this film and on top of
doing an amazing job he knew how to set
tone and the way he did that was with
music so at the start of a meeting if
we're looking at a specific sequence
whether it's you know visual effects or
script or something like that or even
ahead of filming a scene he would just
say you know I've got 45 seconds of
something I want to play for you or a
minute and he just you know pull up
something sometimes it's something he
wrote sometimes it was something from
one of his movies sometimes it was a
song he knew and he's like this is the
tone to the scene you're like oh
everyone's on board because music is
such an emotional but also a universal
language and so it's something before
that you know working with some of the
background of music like that is an
incredible asset because you're like
okay this scene's supposed to be scary I
need to feel attention here no we're
going to up swing to a little levity oh
we got to drop it back down and
Michael's uh ability to communicate that
with music and his knowledge was
incredible so because it's on Disney
plus there is no mandated run time did
you guys ever discuss having a longer
version of it or a shorter version how
did you end up with the run time are you
asking for the eight hour director's cut
no I'm not asking for that but you know
like it could have been an hour and five
minutes it could have also been 40
minutes right no you know we knew that
we wanted it to to be a special and be a
taste and like I said we're sort of
angling for um old Network specials of
the day which we're usually 30 minutes
to an hour and so we were aiming in that
realm things like you know A Charlie
Brown Christmas or across the Snowman
are not things that we I'm saying
emulated but that concept of like oh
it's a special you see during a season
or around a certain holiday or a certain
time of year
um and so we just sort of settled on
what felt right it's it's one night it
all happens in one night it's quick you
go through it and and afterwards you're
wondering what's happening next with
Jack and Elsa I'm out of time but I just
got to ask you real fast
um I heard the new Ant-Man turned out
pretty great uh would you care to
comment on that I'd say we're still
working on it but I will say those
incredibly talented cast
um and everyone really brought their a
game and Peyton Reed is is the best
person to have at the helm he has such a
great sense of of what the comedy should
be but also the stakes and I can't wait
it's a few more months but I can't wait
to show it because I think it's a really
great new direction for Ant-Man I've
heard good things on that note
um have a fantastic day and seriously
people are gonna love this oh thanks so
much